tout d'abord la tenue de nuit l'oréal 1
qu'elle a vraiment chez elle de nadège
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
christophe carrière
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok c'est ma fille s'est fait un carton
en battant c'est vraiment le genre de
tenues que vous mettez le soir pour
dormir
oui non pas la gemmi le tee shirt de
soirée parce que voilà d'habitude ce
t-shirt là je ne mets pas tout le temps
parce qu'il n'est pas vous avez raison
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut pas pour
le prodige yamaha et authentique c'est
vrai c'est que c'est pas sexy eric à la
nuit tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je m'attendais je ne vous le
cache pas j'ai un truc un peu plus
affriolants sa lé confort oui c'est
qu'on force les choses sont amendés faut
chasser les chaussures vosgien donc de
laine de mouton je sais pas grand mais
c'est peut-être bientôt qu'il va falloir
aller coucher les enfants ont parlé tout
à l'heure de plus belle la vie à côté
c'est du pipi de chat
car voici isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais attendez zabel retour mais avec
certains le soir vous êtes comme ça chez
moi je veux rancune hot
oui mais j'avais quand même pas venir en
culotte et infliger ça aux enfants ont
presque enfants attention spectacle
américain mr gros tuyaux
[Applaudissements]
cette seule scène et vous dire c'est du
fellini
mais pourquoi le mousse yoyo partie
priori pas ce qu'il a dit tout à l'heure
quand le surnommer gros tuyaux mais vous
imaginez que ce type est directeur de
magazines de presse il arrive puis comme
ça en se faisant avec le public qui
hurlent groothuis toronto mais le show
wen au mont d'or
carole et les turbines
[Applaudissements]
là
tiens
[Applaudissements]
voyez vous pourriez vous être l'annoncé
je suis même prêt à prendre le pari vous
la mettez là ne dit rien pendant 45
minutes à bien la courbe d'audience en
un regard de la
publie ces jours-ci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la chambre à coucher le soir au coucher
pour jean-michel de son bureau
ok travail là c'est pour les castes et
c'est hugh hefner le patron de playboy
72 on signe de respect pour ma personne
[Applaudissements]